emily you've been following so you think
she's legitimate katanji brown yeah uh
would define legitimate well do you
support her for supreme court no no no
no no no no no i mean i think she's an
activist um i think she's an activist
judge um and you know it's a it's an
interesting question because the senate
sort of caught in this period where
there used to be courtesy um votes in
favor of a president's nominee right and
then they got away from that and so now
you still have the people like the mitt
romneys of the world and the lindsey
grahams of the world and the susan
collins of the world who think you know
if somebody's qualified we give them the
courtesy vote they're the president's
choice etc etc but nobody on the left or
the right i mean that's that's a
minority position on the left or the
right and the left and the right will
pretend that's the consensus position um
in when it is favorable to them but this
is a case where you have very much an
activist judge and you have this this
questioning process it's sort of a given
that she's going to be confirmed um but
the questioning process is being treated
as though in in a number of different
ways like i sat down with marsha
blackburn last week and i said to her
there is a 100 chance that next week
you are going to be called a racist it
is inevitable that whatever you say in
your questioning you are going to be
called a racist how do you respond to
that is it time for republicans and i
actually mentioned ron desantis to start
flipping these questions to start um
changing the narrative and to stop
accepting the premises of these
questions um and i think we see a little
bit of grappling with that on the right
you definitely see it in desantis you
definitely see it with trump but i'm not
sure that everyone has has fully gotten
to it because when you look at what
happened with the kavanaugh confirmation
hearing as has been invoked by many
senators just in the early days of uh
judge brown jackson judge brown
jackson's confirmation hearing it's
night and day i mean it's incredible how
you have dick durbin coming out and
saying some of the questions to judge
jackson have been uh you know teetering
near the line i was like what the hell
were you guys doing with kavanaugh then
what were you doing questioning amy
coney barrett's faith what were you
doing um what was the media doing when
they were talking about whether she
might be a racist because ibra makes
candy best-selling author ibra mike's
candy extremely powerful author and
commentator even max kennedy comparing
her to a white colonizer because she
adopted black children a little bit a
little bit close to the line there dick
i was speaking at an event and uh we had
it we opened up for questions and uh
stixx and hammer was
you know coming in via zoom or what
wasn't doing a skype or whatever back
then and someone asked a question about
defending an individual for something
they had said and the individual was
like a white nationalist something so it
felt kind of like a woke journalist tee
up to write about and uh as soon as it
came up i was like are you referring to
that guy who's you know who has been
reported to be a white nationalist is
that what you're trying to ask about and
then stixx immediately came in and he
said we shouldn't dismiss people based
on opinions that aren't relevant to the
conversation we should answer to the the
topic that's being brought up before us
so we can actually question the idea you
know we can't fall into that trap of
someone being a bad person and all of a
sudden the idea they present is
dismissed out right because the person
said it's bad anybody could have an idea
like two plus two is four you know what
do they say hitler had a dog too right
and i just thought that was an excellent
response so you know bring this up when
we're looking at what's happening with
uh
the media trying to accuse you or smear
you as being racist it's just you have
to completely disregard it as unserious
and irrelevant but the problem i think
we have is that many republicans care
more about the opinion of the new york
times than their own constitution yeah
they still do and that's what's that is
what is confounding and so yeah no i was
just gonna say so
you've seen senator hawley right who's
really done the work you know that's the
new phrase right now do the work
um he's actually done the work of
digging up her record on these lighter
than required sentences rather than
later than suggested sentences for child
porn offenders and child porn
distribution we should probably talk
about this issue because she's bringing
up you know saying well it's different
now these laws were written
during a time of child pornography
distribution by mail and so it was
harder to accumulate
this many uh this such a large volume of
it and so because of each instance of
possessing
an item of child you know child
pornography then it beca it meant that
that person was a more serious offender
but because of the internet now it is
easier to accumulate large volumes and
so it created what she called a
disparity in the system
whereas you know i think most normal
people looking at that would say
well doesn't that just mean it's easier
to victimize children so probably be
harder against it because it's so much
easier to victimize children with child
porn other than when it was in the past
and you had to do this very
surreptitiously um and it also strikes
me to that point as what you just said
that that's a very activist argument
right if you don't like it it's a lot of
things to be an activist for to be
completely honest
right you know isn't that isn't that
that thing you know you know if somebody
keeps talking about it then they you
know we have to ask questions about why
they keep talking about well why is this
the one thing that she seems to be such
an activist for you know uh apologizing
i'm so sorry that you're going to feel
shunned now by society you know i i
think that you know you're a good kid
and you only really need three months i
mean it was just a couple of
eight-year-olds you're not that much
older this actually was something that
she said during sentencing at one point
that 18 isn't that much older than eight
so it's not that bad isn't there a
recording of hillary clinton laughing or
something like a child victim or
something like that yes yeah she was she
was laughing it was in court yeah i
would have to go back and look at the i
think she was she was involved she was
arguing a case in arkansas if i'm
remembering correctly she was definitely
she was defending the race right yeah
yeah um but but this is the thing with
even the people attacking holly admit
that what judge jackson did was
predicated on this distinction just as
as jack just explained and yet you have
the media george stephanopoulos
literally saying that holly's claims
have been debunked by a fact checker
debunked by a fact checker that's a man
who purports to be an anchor at a
neutral news network saying that it's
been debunked by a fact checker which
completely neutralizes the argument to
the public as though josh hawley is some
insane person who's peddling outright
lies but even the defenders even the
people who are attacking holly are
saying that what he said is accurate
they just say listen there's this
argument in criminal justice reform
circles that you can you really do need
to give lighter sentences in these cases
that the congressional mandatory minimum
is wrong and so is there maybe merit to
that argument i don't know perhaps i
mean it sounds like it well if she wants
to make that argument she can run for
congress exactly and she can change the
law because that's how separation of
powers works the legislative body is the
one that's supposed to do that not the
justice and we don't need more judicial
activism on the court and certainly we
don't need judicial activism when it
comes to child pornography you see
what's going on now with the this
political report of this democrats are
trying to get joe biden to bypass
congress to push for the progressive
agenda because they know congress is
basically deadlocked
so
it just sounds more and more with these
activist judges
that our traditional legislative system
has failed a long time ago i think most
people agree this approval for congress
is just absolutely in the gutter it's
like record lows
so everyone's just sitting there saying
well
representative democracy for legislation
doesn't work get a judge to just bang a
hammer or get joe biden to sign a paper
well and that's the right point here
because that's exactly why we have these
super bitter supreme court confirmation
battles it's because the legislative
branch has kicked the can to the
judiciary into the executive because
they no longer function as the
legislative branch should 100 yeah it's
it's actually really really scary i mean
when was the last time that congress
declared war right world war ii right
yeah
1941
wow it's scary
following pearl harbor right so i think
the ninth
yeah i mean the bait like we take for
granted how actually dysfunctional our
system is like obviously we know it's
dysfunctional but we take for granted
how deep the dysfunction is and how like
actually foundational fundamental it is
to the way we operate as a country yeah
when we started the country there's a
bunch of private sector dudes a bunch of
and their wives who we really know much
about but they they basically got
together and started a new government
and it's like i look at this poorly run
government with a bunch of bureaucrats
they're in there for life
i don't i don't know if it's salvageable
i want to be the guy that's like i want
to preserve the the republic but it's i
was telling you earlier
from the the romance of the three
kingdoms he was obsessed with restoring
the government and he just couldn't it
was a failed attempt but the reason for
this is that the left understood a
generation ago right and the right is
only starting to kind of understand what
happened that their
policy prescriptions would not
you know prevail at the ballot box so if
they could find a bureaucratic or
judicial fix for it then they would go
through that way so they get their
legislation from the bench and you've
seen so many of these social
conservative issues or just social
issues in general be decided through
supreme court cases oh burgerfell o berg
fell or even roe v wade
i think the quintessential you know kcv
planned parenthood right so these these
are all supreme court cases these are
not this was not the original role of
the supreme court whatsoever and the
idea that
katanji brown jackson is saying this
sort of stuff she's actually getting
upset that holly is question calling
these things into question because to
her mind as a a progressive activist
judge she believes that is the role of
the judge to correct what she sees
herself as issues in the law because of
course that's how you correct it that's
what the judiciary is for right the
legislative i mean that withered and
died on the vine years ago exactly yeah
it's it's seeing your it's that is baked
into the role as people see it on the
left that like of course of course
you're offering these corrections that's
what you exist to do and it's a huge
disconnect between left and right but
it's also just a huge disconnect between
the left and the constitution
well i don't think they much care about
the constitution oh no certainly no
regarding like recovering the republic
uh you had mentioned that if we were
gonna do that it would be like we take
the pieces of it that work and then
create new things or or strip away
things that are broken like are there
specific things you'd like to keep and
are the specific ones you like well i
mean i i think that congress obviously
so congress abrogated its role
um of sovereignty a long long time ago
right and so you know something you know
people talk about term limits but
certainly something needs to be done
with terms for congressmen i think
that's i i don't know if term limits are
the right thing because you know if you
introduce term limits then lobbyists are
just going to run things even more than
they do now right so term limits aren't
necessarily the answer but you've also
got an issue in the executive because
the executive and yarvin writes about
this um
where the executive branch has
essentially under and this was this is
very wilsonian wilson was very clear
about doing this you know growing what
he called the you know essentially the
leviathan right this this sort of the
organic state was what he called it um
we call it the administrative state or
the permanent state the bureaucracy the
civil service so this idea that the
academy
and the ivory the ivory tower of the ivy
league would make decisions and then the
executive kind of responds to that
through these independent agencies and
the bureaucracy is actually running the
government and so congr the congress is
there to just kind of rubber stamp those
decisions and this is where you get you
know a dr anthony fauci from because he
comes up not through he's not an elected
official nobody ever voted for this guy
he's the most powerful bureaucrat in all
of washington or he certainly was during
the height of the pandemic his pronoun
he would go on tv literally making
pronouncements that would decide what
your child could do in a local school
right from dc this was the op complete
opposite of how our system is supposed
to work and yet we all went along with
it the best was the double masking cycle
where he got asked you know romney still
does that double mask gosh romney still
doubles saucy got asked about double
masking and they were like isn't it
common sense that two masks would be
good he's like yes of course two masks
would be good and then he comes out
later having to no no no there's no
advice saying you should do it and then
the cd the cdc comes out and says yeah
you should double mask like the idea of
double masking just came from him off
the cuff saying it makes sense to do
right someone heard him say it and then
typed it in and pressed enter and then
all of a sudden everybody was doing it
and by the way masks are bad and they're
taking masks away from our first
responders and that's of course that's
what fouchy and the cdc and actually
basically our entire federal government
was saying and again these people do not
understand and they have not yet
reckoned with the level of distrust that
exists in the public but the big thing
is not only do they have to like reckon
with that they have to not see it as
just abject bigotry right like this is
anybody who disagrees with me is an
idiot toothless rude bigot they have to
understand actually why people distrust
them and understand that the blame lies
with them but that is what they will
absolutely never do well that was the
point i i mentioned earlier where
someone tweeted you know it's time to
remind everybody that brett kavanaugh
was credibly accused by christine blasey
ford and republicans didn't care and
it's like no it's because it was made up
it didn't happen why you wouldn't need
to put the word credibly in front of it
if it was legitimate and it was like 30
years ago her own friends that she
didn't remember it
even didn't even know it was brett and
they're trying to make it seem like yeah
let me just tell you man representatives
squeeze remember squeeze squeeze let me
let me just let me just
say naughty words i'm sorry for a moment
the calendar let me yes the calendar
beers beers babes
they accused a federal judge of being
party to gang rapes plural excuse me not
just they jake tapper jake tapper this
paragon of we're supposed to believe
that he's the most uh you know right
down the line just calling balls and
strikes he had who on air right michael
avenatti
and julie setwick was the client at the
time come on accusing brett kavanaugh at
the time a federal judge and going up
for the highest court in land accused
him of being a member of a gang rape uh
you know you know frat during high
school pages of the new yorker what did
they say like on air they would line up
outside of a room with like a woman
inside and they would go in and just you
know
take turns
that's insane there's there's no
evidence for anything like that and and
no no sane person would believe such a
ridiculous story
but you know what man they just keep
saying it so i have to wonder how many
people actually believe at this point
what they keep saying but and this is a
point that i've made about the riots in
the summer of 2020 and i think it's a
mistake the right makes sometimes is
that like we just are like oh crazy
people etc etc but people rioting in
2020 have been told for their entire
lives um so i was born in 1993 but even
people younger than me they have been
told their entire lives that they live
in a country that is dripping with
racism systemic racism that is evil and
they've been told this from every
institution sexism racism all of these
things are institutional their
institutions are telling them that and
so what do you expect is going to happen
in this country you have to find a way
to sort of like penetrate that audience
make that argument reasonably because
people have been indoctrinated to the
point where they believe and i think
reasonably so if all of your
institutions are telling you this for
years and years and years everyone
everyone is telling you this oprah's
telling you this your teachers are
telling you this it's coming from
everyone i mean yeah you might riot i
mean it's it's it's
not right but you can understand the the
sort of impetus for it the party told
you to reject the evidence of your eyes
and ears it was their final most
essential command and if all others
accepted the lie which the party imposed
if all records told the same tale then
the lie passed into history and became
truth george yeah that's why i just love
it when joe biden's like i was in a
secure meeting with the military officer
said there's going to be a new world
order and they're like that didn't
happen that's a conspiracy right so you
can you actually see it now it's it's
like it's like they it's like somebody
gets on the phone right and calls up and
says oh you've got to get the fact
checkers out you know someone so
effective right now the new york times
right so the the fact checkers that's
actually if you understand the npc mean
the non-player character meme so a fact
check is actually just a software
upgrade for the npcs that you have to
push out every time someone short
circuits the false reality short
circuits the simulation
they cut right so it's a patch that has
to be up pushed out every time one of
the npc's comes into contact with actual
reality oh right so anytime that joe
biden comes out and says oh by the way
there's a new world order and i was just
talking to the secret military about
this in this meeting they have to push
out
just so you know or you know josh hawley
comes up and says hey how come you were
given all these uh you know child porn
traffickers these you know
these light sentences whoa whoa whoa we
have to put out a factor and if you
notice and lydia you were even talking
about this earlier that in the fact
checks right
all the fact checks admitted that holly
was correct yeah yeah they did but they
just box reason yeah
they try to explain it away and yet they
label it as a fact check yeah and it
never once says fact check true because
it was this is they just say it's been
fact checked i included this i did a
segment earlier on the joe biden new
world order thing and there's a website
called logically that is a fact checker
and they said you know uh ukrainian mp
passively mentioned a new world order
triggering widespread conspiracies it
was taken out of context and here's what
they did it was an amazing it was
actually i shouldn't say amazing it was
amazing that they attempted to pull this
off they said the new world order
conspiracy theory is very similar to the
great reset and the great reset
conspiracy is just wrong to the
ukrainian mp was not talking about any
kind of great reset and i'm like yes she
wasn't she literally said new world
order but they just did this leapfrog
where it's like did the ukrainian mp
discuss a conspiracy about a great reset
false while she did say she's fighting
for a new world order she did not talk
about a great reason that's the game
they play you're right they are both
similar in the extent that they're both
the explicit ambitions of the global
elite so if these people are lying to
you and we know they've lied to us about
kavanaugh we know they've lied to us
about
russiagate we
can see that they're lying to us in real
time about judge jackson yet we're told
that we have to believe every single
utterance they make about what's
happening in ukraine thousands of miles
away where we don't have direct contacts
unless you're going to these places like
telegram
like you know using vpns getting other
places having to translate it to
actually find out what's going on on the
ground yet we're just about to take that
all as true well the basically the
country expo experienced a soft coup
when woodrow wilson was president when
the federal reserve was formed and they
took control and it's been and they lied
about it we didn't know people didn't
know about it until 15 years ago and
then the internet broke out and lose
change came out you start to realize the
the federal reserve and the print
they lied the whole time this whole
organization has been they pulled the
wool over the american people's eyes to
print their money and take their their
sons to war
so check this out we talked about the
value of a nickel on the show a couple
weeks ago and we read somewhere that it
was like a nickel is 75 percent what i
think copper and 25 nickel and because
nickel is skyrocketing and like actual
metal that the value of a nickel is
actually up the value of a nickel right
now is actually 10 cents
now you can't destroy currency but we're
in this weird time where the legal
currency of the nickel is worth less
than what the actual medal is worth yeah
and so
good luck buying nickels no no no no
joke
go online and try and get nickels for
your business
it's it's no wonder there was a coin
coin shortage during covet because
people were probably hoarding all of
their nickels because it's just
the the nothing i forgot why i brought
this up what were we talking about a
moment ago nickel man let's go deep oh
about the federal reserve oh right right
right the federal reserve i'm just
thinking about how currency became
completely nonsensical it used to be
that you
you'd have silver dimes nickels and
quarters were made of specific specific
metals that had value and and you knew
that a quarter was a specific amount of
that metal
now
nothing makes sense pennies are made of
like zinc copper plated copper-plated
zinc but nickels for some reason still
have nickel but now nickels through the
roof so that's not going to make sense
for much longer the federal reserve at
some point i'm just i'm looking at these
news reports about how the government
was like we hereby order all people to
give their gold to the government just
think about when it was like 1933 right
yeah was it when when when they were
like you have to turn all of your gold
over crazy imagine the government coming
to your house and saying you give us all
your money
like hey putin invaded ukraine you have
to give us everything you own yeah no no
jokes that's worth the wait people were
just like yep did you see this um hitler
wasn't i'm just seeing somebody come
across that uh this thing that tucker
had tonight
about the fbi and kbj's nomination
interesting so
apparently tucker got an email that went
out uh internally with the fbi in their
la office that the the fbi's la women's
and black affairs committee held
a nomination
party for katanji brown jackson
the invitation reads lots of celebrating
the party is set for march 23rd so
that's tomorrow and
in a conference christy coons
the assistant director in charge of the
la field office is the featured speaker
so they're actually holding nomination
parties for a partisan
political
appointee
of the president united states in the
fbi's office didn't you hear that they
were they they recently changed the name
to uh fbdi the federal bureau of
democratic investigations oh
right no no no the fbi is totally
neutral totally
do not take sides i also
hr the federal bureau of democratic
investigations and we hate republicans
well it turns out we're all right and
james
yeah because we live in a republic no no
no yes no we're all republicans because
we're all irredeemable bigots oh yeah i
mean i think literally we're all we're
all living a republic so we're all right
yes yes but i think except as stephen
marsh pointed on the show i'm a team the
country is a multicultural democracy and
the other half of the constitutional
republic
of republicans that's actually a great
point yeah
doesn't believe
or even acknowledge the constitutional
republic right um i remember you know
talking to people
who had gone like to public school you
know a friend of mine when i was you
know still working they would say well
you know did you know that we're
actually not a democracy and i looked at
them like yeah i mean obviously right
you know how could you not know that but
they're like but my whole life i was
taught the united states is a democracy
and we need to be a democracy so we need
to get rid of this constitution thing
that's what they're taught whoa who was
that
was a friend of mine growing up oh okay
but had been through this completely
separate educational track than i had
been through um i was all catholic
school she was all um you know public
high school public grade school and
like was a very upset and emotional over
the fact
that she found out later on that
actually in fact we were a
constitutional republic i went through a
phase where i really disliked the um the
house of representatives just as an
institution and i thought they were
getting bribed i mean i still don't like
that they're bribed
targets what do you mean
they don't like
it
i was like
get rid of the house of representatives
and michael is like that's going a
little too far in um i went through a
phase where i just i drank water to
survive
oh yeah me too i'm still in that face
were you breathing air too i've thought
about it wow what it came to is like i
like the institution i like the function
of the republic just that there's a stop
gap between the the citizens and then
the
legislators uh but i don't think they
need to be people i think it could be
like organized mechanically with like
smart contracts and things right because
the people are just too vulnerable it's
a vulnerability in our system they get
bribed
and even if they have term limits the
new ones are going to come in and get
bribed bribe
yeah they're going to keep getting
bribed
but you know i wonder if it's um
many of these members of congress just
don't know they have no principles so
they're simply looking at what gets me
elected the principle is power is it
right yeah it's fascistic right across
the board i don't care if they're it's
majority of republicans save maybe like
the freedom costs caucus a few
republicans almost all of the democratic
party just basically are like all that
matters is power
that's it well mitch mcconnell it's the
mitch mcconnell governing philosophy
it's not about any ideological agenda
it's about maintaining power for the
republican party and that is great for
the lobbyists it's great for the
politicians it's great for that class of
people but if you don't do anything with
that power it completely is telling that
you actually have no who's voting for
this no but this this is actually ram
too this is actually what is confounding
a lot of
our policymakers when it comes to russia
because they say well we're going to go
after the oligarchs because we assume
that the oligarchs control russia the
same way they control the united states
right so they think well in the united
states if we just went after the mega
donors then obviously the politicians
would have to do what we want so they
tried to craft their russia policy based
on how the united states government
works but that's not how the kremlin
works and that's not how like vladimir
putin doesn't answer to his oligarchs
they answer to him it's completely
separate from the way the united states
works so when you look at the way that
they're lashing out at russia it's
actually more relevatory in how the
united states system works because they
assume that's how you can put pressure
on the kremlin because that's how you
would put pressure on the president
united states on the congress on the
senate super short donors and that's
what they did in afghanistan too they
set up an american-style government and
then when they pulled out the american
style people
it's called the liberal world order the
tribal countries no no it is the cfr us
the cfr space website pulled up the cfr
website pulled up the council on foreign
relations said the world bank and the
international monetary fund are how they
implement their liberal world economic
order so you go to these countries and
say
we're basically like it's a bribe
essentially we're going to give you
money for development we're giving this
big loan but that means these countries
become beholden to their debt holders it
rapidly modernizes a country it's good
for a lot of people who live there you
know the standard of living skyrockets
but other countries behold into who
holds there i think chile is going
through that right now their standard of
living just exploded in the last 20 or
30 years but right then you've got
coca-cola and then you've got countries
that reject it like belarus
syria
libya
iraq under saddam afghanistan obviously
a variety of reasons north korea for a
variety of reasons and so all of those
countries are there for evil and they
must be destroyed
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you